I noticed some funny posts this morning
on the David packman show subreddit of
course you can join nearly 26 000 of our
viewers and listeners at
davidpackman.com Reddit
um there is a very funny post that is a
screenshot of oan oan is one America
news this is the alternative to Fox News
that Donald Trump has been recommending
they are even crazier and they put up a
delusional map of what they say is the
real electoral map from this election
and it has it has Donald Trump with four
410 electoral votes and um it the
headline is reports seized
s-c-y-t-l data
shows Landslide win for president Trump
so they're going to be very very
disappointed on January 20th but that is
what Donald Trump is recommending uh
Newsmax and oan are the recommended
alternatives to Fox News that Trump is
pushing people towards also a post
reminding us that yes a 87 year old
Republican senator Chuck Grassley has
tested positive for Coronavirus now you
might remember there was this absolutely
surreal picture or even it might have
been video or certainly pictures of
shortly after the Super spreader event
which led to there was that short period
of time where a bunch of Republicans got
the virus including Donald Trump Senator
Ron Johnson Senator Mike Lee within days
of being diagnosed with the virus there
was a senate hearing at which Mike Lee
who who was coveted positive was
standing above 87 year old Republican
senator Chuck Grassley at a senate
hearing with no mask talking to someone
it might have been Lindsey Graham or
somebody else and we looked and said how
does how does Chuck Grassley if this is
what's going on
how the hell does Chuck Grassley avoid
getting coronavirus and indeed 87 year
old Chuck Grassley now has coronavirus
of course I never wish illness nor death
on anybody statistically speaking um
Chuck Grassley is at uh quite high risk
at the same time as a senator he has
access to very very good health care and
much like Donald Trump got access to
things which the average person would
not have access to it's certainly
conceivable Chuck Grassley would get the
same and as we know the level of care
that one receives can make a major major
difference in uh whether who there's
this there's actually this crazy story
of a covet ICU
where uh one person they were so
overloaded that nursing and medical
attention was extremely limited but
there was one patient in there that was
the wife of a doctor that worked in that
hospital she was designated a so-called
VIP and for a short period of time she
was the one uh serious covid patient
that survived so understand that Health
Access to Health Care disparities make a
major major difference when fighting the
with a lot of conditions it's not just
coronavirus uh Chuck Grassley with
coronavirus joined the discussion at
davidpackman.com Reddit one of our
sponsors is privacy.com they're giving
you five dollars when you sign up for
their completely free service at
privacy.com Pacman I've been using
privacy for a little over a year now
you've heard me talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone instead of actually using your
real credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even auto fill the card number
with one click and the payment is taken
out of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a 10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cash back and lets you
create 36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like I
said you'll get five dollars to spend
when you sign up at privacy.com Pacman